سأطرح عليك سؤالاً
أفترض أنه ربما يكون من الصعب الإجابة عليه ولكن
بناءً على الوصف الذي لدينا، فإن هذا
بحجم سيارة صغيرة
وكان حوالي أربعين ألف قدم
غير قابلة للمناورة وعندما يسمع الناس
البطاقة الصغيرة الذكية لا  إذا فكرت في
كثافة السيارة فكر في هذا
الحجم فقط، هل هناك أي شيء
تعتقد أنه من الممكن أن يكون هذا محتملًا، هل
يمكننا استبعاد أن هذا العنصر كان
نعم، هذا سؤال رائع فيكتور
أعتقد أنك تعرف ما هو
قد تكون الاحتمالات أنه في
الواقع بالون طقس آه كما تعلم
لذا لا يمكننا استبعاد ذلك
تمامًا آه الشيء الرئيسي الذي آه
ركزت عليه هو أنه من الواضح أن هذا
الكائن لم يكن لديه نوع
القدرة الاتصالية آه مثل
البالون  هل اه أصبحت هذه
قضية مختلفة تمامًا وأنت تعرف ما
كان يقوله الرائد ليونز، هناك
فرق كبير من
منظور جمع المعلومات الاستخبارية،
لا بأس في الواقع في بعض الحالات اه لجمع
المعلومات لمعرفة كيف تتحدث فعليًا مع
الكيانات الأخرى  في هذه الحالة بالذات،
لديك موقف مختلف قليلًا
حيث لم تتحدث مع
أي شيء ولكنك لا تعرف نوع
الوضعيات الملولبة باستثناء حقيقة
أنك تعلم أنها تشكل تهديدًا للطيران التجاري